es que se acerca un proceso electoral
nos enfrentamos a una realidad un poco
cómica un poco triste a la vez tenemos
que elegir entre el más guapo el menos
malo el que conocemos de toda la vida o
el outsider una auténtica ruleta rusa y
estas jornadas son sólo posibles gracias
a los antojitos que te encuentras de
afuera de los recintos electorales por
nada la cabeza
yo soy parte de una generación que
creció en medio de una crisis a todo
nivel política institucional social
entre finales de los 90 y principios de
la década del 2000 vimos a siete
presidentes desfilar por carondelet en
diez años y luego uno en toda la década
vaya a cambio ya llevamos casi 40 años
de una democracia por cierto convulsa
donde los procesos de participación han
sido reducidos o ya de plano
inexistentes
esta generación realmente tiene
intereses diversos y lo que pasa es que
hemos estado viviendo una de las
revoluciones más importantes y drásticas
de la historia de la humanidad la
revolución digital
y esta revolución ha hecho que nos
achaquen cierta apatía política no nos
interesa lo que está pasando con nuestro
país ni quién lo gobierna pero yo creo
que no es tanto eso
me parece que la máxima aristotélica de
que somos animales políticos está más
vigente que nunca lo que pasa es que los
formatos han cambiado entre la y la
política por supuesto no está ajena a
ese cambio
hoy vengo a hablar de lo que podemos
hacer como ciudadanos para tener una
mejor democracia y para eso traigo el
ejemplo de una iniciativa de la que soy
parte
se llama ecuador decide y nació en
diciembre del 2016 con un carácter
eminentemente ciudadano plural e
independiente de fuerzas políticas o de
partidos políticos en general
gracias al apoyo de un centro de
investigación que tiene 14 años de
experiencia y creía en el potencial de
este proyecto
el objetivo principal cerrar esta brecha
informativa que venía existiendo entre
ciudadanía y política donde esferas muy
acostumbradas a mirarse desde lejos como
si se tratase de extraños
y como en todo proyecto que nace
teníamos muchas preguntas en la cabeza
por ejemplo cómo se hace una política
pública de dónde sale de dónde nace una
oferta de campaña y cómo nos podemos
asegurar de que esa oferta efectivamente
se cumpla
bueno había que juntar algunos elementos
clave por un lado innovar para generar
incidencia y teniendo en cuenta de que
en este proceso hay muchos actores
involucrados por ejemplo candidatos
también la sociedad civil pero
fundamentalmente la ciudadanía gente
como yo gente como ustedes que necesitan
acceder a información oportuna y
entender los procesos electorales de una
forma más amplia la tecnología por
supuesto nos da una oportunidad
interesante porque significa cambiar
formatos y convertirlos en
y espacios accesibles para que la gente
pueda acceder a información en
diferentes ámbitos
vamos a poner ahora una pregunta clave
quien podría decir que participó
activamente en el último proceso
electoral
pocos no bueno lo que pasa es que
estamos muy acostumbrados a pensar en
los procesos electorales como solamente
el día en el que vamos a votar pero
la verdad es que tenemos aquí un ciclo
una especie de círculo que hace falta
irse rands en donde el día de las
votaciones por cierto es uno de los
puntos más importantes pero también hay
cosas pasando antes y después no vamos a
poner el caso de pepe un ciudadano
promedio que va a las urnas
pero en realidad ir a votar es la punta
del iceberg y lo que el pp no sabe es
que muchas cosas pasando allá debajo la
labor de este proyecto ha pasado
justamente por visibilizar todo esto
hagamos de cuenta que se trata de una
escalera a la que le faltan peldaños
nuestra labor ha pasado precisamente por
ir colocando esos peldaños en un orden
en el que vayamos apuntando a una
partición una participación un poco más
efectiva de los actores principales
entonces cuáles son y cómo los hemos ido
colocando vamos a hacer un repaso muy
breve
el primer punto muy importante sería
escuchar a los candidatos los que nos
tienen que decir las propuestas que nos
trae y para eso el debate sin duda es
una de las herramientas más efectivas
el debate entendido como el intercambio
de ideas y no tanto como un ring de
boxeo que es como a veces lo pensamos
tampoco es una mala palabra porque la
hemos desterrado un poco del lenguaje
ciudadano pero en realidad los debates
son procesos importantes que nos van a
permitir conocer esas propuestas que
luego se van a aterrizar a la realidad
en ecuador decide pensamos en el espacio
diálogos y debates con candidatos y
candidatos a la asamblea nacional en las
elecciones de 2017 en cinco provincias
del país participaron entonces 44
candidatos en total de 16 organizaciones
políticas
tuvimos a 100.000 personas siguiendo en
vivo y en directo las incidencias de
estos espacios vía redes sociales porque
claro uno puede llenar un teatro y hay
gente que viene presencialmente a verlo
como hoy pero hay mucha más que por
diferentes factores no puede estar
también pensamos en ellos
luego es el momento de informarte y esto
es re lavar un poco más personal más
individual del ciudadano es conocer esos
planes de gobierno esas propuestas que
están en algún lado
y que tenemos que saber interpretarlas
bueno resulta que en ecuador los planes
de gobierno no tienen un formato
definido hay uno que te puedes encontrar
de cinco páginas y otro de más de 100
entonces eso plantea un reto importante
porque por un lado
no tenemos la posibilidad de juntar los
mismos temas y por el otro estos temas
son dispares lo que planteamos aquí fue
la plataforma que se llama voto informal
un espacio en el que los candidatos y
candidatas a la presidencia en este caso
en 2017 pudieron plantearle a la
ciudadanía sus principales propuestas en
un mismo formato y apuntando a temas
claves que a todos nos interesa salud de
educación reformas institucionales lucha
contra la corrupción pensando en ese
trabajador en ese estudiante que no
tiene tiempo de ponerse a buscar en los
periódicos o entrar a la página del
consejo electoral a mirar los planes
sino que necesita más bien algo rápido
que se pueda ver en el bus o en el auto
mientras está en un semáforo pensar
justamente en esos formatos diferentes
dinámicos y múltiples juntarlo todo
en una sola plataforma
después hay que mencionar algo
importante tuvimos como aliado a la red
social más grande del mundo y esto nos
permitió la oportunidad de poner en
práctica una herramienta con el
ciudadano como enfoque principal un
botón especial que aparecía en la
sección de noticias de los usuarios que
tuvieran como lugar de residencia el
ecuador y que fueran mayores de 16 años
que es la edad habilitante para votar
aquí
repetimos este proceso ya en el
referéndum y consulta popular de 2018
ahora con organizaciones sociales y
políticas que estaban a favor del sig y
a favor del no tomando en cuenta por
supuesto las siete preguntas que estaban
planteadas con infografías con vídeos
aparte de las propuestas
el tercer paso en este ciclo sería la
capacitación que es bien importante
porque uno necesita conocer las
herramientas que luego va a poder usar
las que de pronto tiene a la mano pero
no conoce aquí nuestra experiencia paso
por darle a la gente un curso de
mecanismos de participación que te hagan
precisamente conocer ese ciclo del que
empecé hablando al inicio
aquí tuvimos
60 participantes de 9 provincias del
país que estuvieron en cuatro módulos
aprendían herramientas prácticas y
también tenían cursos online para
facilitar la interacción dado que
estaban en diferentes partes del país y
eran personas que trabajaban tanto en
gobiernos locales partidos políticos
pero también ciudadanos en general
interesados
enterarse y en participar aunque no
estén en una plataforma política activa
luego viene
la oportunidad de hacer propuestas como
ya conoces estos mecanismos tienes a
disposición también la oportunidad de
generar tus propias propuestas desde las
necesidades que tienes como una persona
común y corriente pero que de pronto
mira las problemáticas que suceden a su
alrededor
esto puede ser tu barrio tu ciudad o tu
país aquí la experiencia se llama
ciudadanizando la política y este
componente paso por hacer propuestas de
política pública ya desde la ciudadanía
aquí teníamos temas como violencia de
género educación bachillerato para
jóvenes que no han podido terminar el
ciclo escolar y colegial pero también
por ejemplo movilidad sostenible un tema
que afecta mucho a las grandes ciudades
acá en el país y alrededor del mundo
cuatro de estas propuestas lograron
incidir directamente y entrar en la
agenda del gobierno fueron presentadas
en 2017 y después de un proceso ahora
están
a pasos de ser también ya políticas
públicas que tienen una rectoría y que
van a convertirse efectivamente en
ciudad en soluciones para la ciudadanía
el quinto punto después de que pasa este
proceso vendría a ser verificar y
evaluar y cómo se puede hacer esto pues
tenemos la experiencia de una plataforma
que llamamos del dicho al hecho y esto
es de un poco pasar de las propuestas a
la práctica tú en el plan de gobierno
candidato x nos propuso este tan tal
cosa y vamos a ver cómo ha avanzado por
eso con la llegada al poder del nuevo
presidente inauguramos este proceso que
pasó por construir una plataforma que
nos permita efectivamente comprobar los
avances del gobierno en seis temáticas
principales seis áreas estratégicas y
tomando en cuenta tres períodos al
cumplir los primeros 100 días luego a
los 6 meses y en el primer año
es un periodo clave porque es donde se
está construyendo el proyecto de
gobierno que va a tener un total de 4
años pero el primer año donde suceden
las cosas tanto había presupuestos como
de pronto lo que estás planteando cómo
lo vas a llevar a la práctica desde la
planificación pero no quedó sólo ahí
porque entendemos que es bien importante
dar que estas herramientas pasen también
a tener un uso efectivo por parte de la
gente entonces aunque nosotros proveemos
una calificación que por cierto no está
basada sólo en opiniones subjetivas sino
que tiene indicadores que te van a ir
permitiendo conocer el avance más allá
de la opinión personal que tú tengas
también los ciudadanos pueden darle su
propia votación darles su propia
calificación puedes acceder a votar
puedes ver un vídeo donde te dice cuáles
fueron los principales hitos que cumplió
o no el gobierno y por supuesto también
puedes dejar tus comentarios
es parte de un proceso muy importante
que tiene que ver con el empoderamiento
efectivo es decir pasa podemos podemos
estar en un punto crítico pero también
conocer efectivamente cuáles han sido
los avances o no de una gestión en
particular
entonces de esta manera vamos cerrando
el ciclo que una vez que llega a su
último punto va también a volver a
iniciar y esto pasa por conocer las
propuestas de los candidatos darle
seguimiento y también ir conociendo poco
a poco sus resultados
es pasar de la queja a la crítica
qué es pasar de la queja y la crítica a
la acción es parte de un proceso de
empoderamiento muy importante en el que
tenemos que pensar nos como el eje
central el ciudadano como el actor
principal de esta historia que por un
lado ha estado alejado por muchos años
pero tiene la oportunidad de estar
presente en los procesos electorales
mucho más allá de ir a votar cada uno
dos tres o cuatro años según nuestros
sistemas nos lo vayan imponiendo y más
allá de tener un papel o un certificado
que nos permita hacer otro tipo de
trámites aquí el ejemplo más importante
que me deja ecuador decide es la
posibilidad que tenemos de colaborar
desde diferentes sectores desde la
academia desde la sociedad civil del
propio gobierno en un proceso que tiene
que ver con la corresponsabilidad porque
para que una propuesta pase
efectivamente a la
tiene que haber todo un proceso en el
que nosotros como ciudadanos tenemos la
oportunidad de seguirlo de cerca
quiero decirles también que una de las
cosas más importantes que puedo dejar
como mensaje es que para mí
no importa tanto donde se generen las
propuestas porque hoy he traído el caso
de ecuador pero estamos hablando de los
mismos problemas en democracias
alrededor del mundo méxico israel eeuu
canadá áfrica hacia todos afrontando los
mismos retos y los mismos problemas
de pronto democracias que necesitan
consolidarse que están pensando en la
institucionalidad pero que también
tienen amenazas de por medio regímenes
autoritarios y personalistas que se
ciernen alrededor del mundo y nosotros
tenemos la oportunidad de responder a
estos retos y tenemos la oportunidad de
ser recordados como la generación que
efectivamente hizo algo para solucionar
esos problemas o simplemente se quedó
sentada yo sé que un clic de pronto no
es se pueden interpretar como simple
activismo de sofá
pero también puede ser el inicio para un
cambio fundamental un cambio de
pensamiento
y pensar y repensar la democracia el
tipo de sistema y el tipo de democracia
que queremos y hay un elemento sin el
que todo esto realmente sería imposible
necesitamos romper la indiferencia
el sueño que tenemos la pasión que
tenemos la he venido a compartir hoy con
ustedes porque son porque es para
ustedes por quienes trabajamos con más
ahínco todos los días y cada vez
necesitamos que en cada proceso que se
viene en su participación sea mucho más
allá y mucho más activa y más grande y
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]